they've got him now the walls are
closing in on Donald Trump I know that
we've heard that at least a dozen times
before but now the Democrats are super
duper serious because this time they've
issued Trump a subpoena to appear before
the January 6th committee
I am offering this resolution
that the committee direct the chairman
to issue a subpoena
for Relevant documents and testimony
under oath from Donald John Trump
in connection with the January 6th
attack on the United States capital
nope
nope I don't think so
they can issue whatever subpoena they
want and they can okay they can go on TV
and talk about the subpoena and how this
is it and the walls are closing in Trump
should not even waste time reading it
because that's subpoena like the entire
committee is a complete joke
the selfish part of me wants Trump to
appear because it would be absolutely
hilarious and probably the best TV of
the past two years
but Congress has absolutely no right to
drag the man before them
presidents have been subpoenaed a few
times in the past president John Tyler
actually indulged Congress a John Quincy
Adams gave congress a sworn deposition
so he's sort of half indulged them and
Harry Truman basically told them to
pound sand Truman said he'd be happy to
oblige if the congressman wanted to
quote inquire into any acts as a private
individual either before or after his
presidency and unrelated to any acts as
president but if the subpoena concerned
his actions as President Truman could
not Ascend to that because it would
violate the separation of powers
Truman was right and president Trump
should follow his example whenever he
gets through laughing at them I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment ESPN is from Jeff Caldwell who
says a bill worth of Damages for Alex
Jones well I guess the courts are
experiencing the same bite inflation
that we all are a very good point that
people are not covering yes it does seem
a tad excessive that Alex Jones for
saying something that that was untrue
and that people don't like on his radio
program would have to pay a billion
dollars out but you know frankly in the
Biden economy that's the cost of about
four pumpkin spice lattes so maybe maybe
you're right maybe that the Judgment was
more prudent and reasonable than we
thought when when you want to discuss
these sorts of matters and all other
sorts of matters when you want to talk
to your friends and family you got to
check out Pure Talk head on over to
puretalk.com enter code Knowles with the
midterms coming up here is something
that you ought to keep in mind every
dollar that you spend is a vote and you
are casting those votes again and again
again for companies that are working
hard to undermine everything you believe
in for instance Verizon Wireless
customers you are supporting a company
that canceled one America news for their
support of Donald Trump ATT customers
your wireless provider doesn't just
support the far left CNN they own it
T-Mobile customers your CEO openly
advised Democrats on how to beat Trump
in the 2020 election don't give your
money to woke wireless companies stop it
give it to pure talk instead pure talk
not only believes in conservative
American Family Values but they also
give you the best service at a low cost
unlimited talk text and plenty of data
for just 30 dollars a month the average
family saves almost one thousand dollars
per year that's a thousand fewer votes
for those cell companies that want to
keep you from speaking freely I
absolutely love it incredible incredible
service I have and use pure talk now is
your chance to show Corporate America
you are done funding their leftist
ideologies go to puretalk.com and enter
code at Knolls save 50 off your first
month incredible deal on an already
incredible deal go to puretalk.com promo
code Knowles for 50 off your first month
they've got him now
the wall he's done it now that Trump
that trumpy we're gonna they're gonna
impeach him again
I know he's not in office anymore and
they already impeached him twice didn't
convict him either time obviously but
they're they're going to do it again
Doug got it
meanwhile
that's a little little noticed story a
Joe Biden appears to have committed an
actually impeachable offense
this is according to Reuters
Joe Biden is vowing consequences for
Saudi Arabia after an OPEC decision
to cut the oil supply the oil production
now how did this happen well according
to Saudi Arabia Joe Biden came to them
begging on his hands and knees begging
them not to cut oil production before
the midterm elections because Biden is
completely sunk on every single issue
and one of the biggest drivers of his
dismal popularity ratings is the cost of
energy which is driving the cost of
everything else up too so he begs them
he says please he's playing politics and
he's saying please don't cut your oil
production until after the midterm
elections just get me through the
elections then you can cut it and screw
over the entire world economy but just
please don't destroy the Democrats
heading into November and OPEC said nope
too bad we're going to cut the oil
production
now so far none of those things are an
impeachable offense
what happened next is the problem which
is that Biden is vowing consequences for
Saudi Arabia so the U.S Saudi
relationship is a complicated one but
it's a very important relationship and
it's been a long-standing uh supportive
Alliance and it's it's benefited both
sides over many many years and it's a
very important relationship
Joe Biden is threatening to damage that
relationship he's he's wielding U.S
government power and a decades-long
Alliance
because Saudi Arabia won't help him try
to do a little bit better in the
elections than he looks like he's going
to do
this is certainly as bad as anything
they ever accused Donald Trump of it's
actually much much worse don't forget
what did they what did the Democrats
impeach Donald Trump for
Democrats impeach Donald Trump for
allegedly calling Ukraine
and and uh requesting that Ukraine
expose some of the corruption that we
know we already know about that the
Biden family engaged in back when Joe
Biden was the vice president and Hunter
Biden Joe's son got a ridiculous crony
deal from the corrupt Ukrainian
government to pay him fifty thousand
dollars or more per month to sit on the
board of barisma a crooked Ukrainian
state-controlled Energy company why do
you think the ukrainians hired Hunter
Biden for that position do you think
it's because Hunter Biden has any
expertise in oil or utility companies or
the Ukrainian language or no of course
he doesn't know anything about any of
those things it was a payoff to Joe
Biden because Joe Biden was the point
man on Ukraine
so the allegation at least was that
Donald Trump
called the ukrainians and said hey
expose the corruption that went on
specifically with Joe Biden in Ukraine
and you remember Joe Biden then
pressured the Ukrainian government to
fire one of their prosecutors who
appeared to have been looking into the
hunter Biden corruption Scandal and at
the very least looking into barisma and
there was a whole bunch of shady stuff
in that very corrupt part of the world
and so Donald Trump was accused of
saying hey ukrainians come clean about
all that corruption and maybe he was
using as leverage a a military payment
it's a military aid which again there
was not a lot of evidence of that either
here
we see very clear evidence Joe Biden is
publicly threatening to punish Saudi
Arabia a long-standing Ally
because they won't help him try to do a
little bit better in the midterm
elections
are they going to impeach Biden for that
no probably not but they certainly
should if the new standard is the Trump
standard of impeachment then this guy
should be thrown in Guantanamo Bay okay
this is absolutely corrupt stuff
speaking of the Muslims really
interesting story out of the Washington
Post this is a report from Michigan that
the Washington Post reported that
Muslims and Christians are teaming up in
Michigan to protest the creepy LGBT
curricula in the schools
so the way the Washington Post reports
it is that this the Christians are the
bad guys and the Muslims were just kind
of duped and brought along for the ride
if you look at the videos by the way it
looks like the Muslims here are actually
leading the show and Muslims are
obviously very very represented because
of mass migration in Michigan and in
Dearborn particular the the they show up
to a Dearborn Public Schools meeting and
they they chant that they want to throw
the bums out because these weirdos in
the schools are trying to trans the kids
and push the rainbow ideology on them
take a listen
vote
[Music]
them out vote them out now as far as I
can tell every single person in that
room is a Muslim I don't I don't see
anyone that looks particularly Christian
uh there at all but the Washington Post
has to frame it they can't frame it as
the Muslims or the bad guys it always
has to be the Christians who are the bad
guys or the white people who are the bad
guys or the men who are the bad guys or
the straight people who are the bad guys
that's the way that their identity
politics works so they say the
Christians are leading this movement
against
LGBT progress and openness and inclusion
in the schools and you know okay yeah
some of the Muslims went along with it
no it's the it's the Muslim I'm sure
Christians back this too I I'll speak as
a Christian I absolutely 100 support
those guys who are in Michigan pushing
back on the LGBT curriculum
but it's the Muslims saying wait a
second we don't want this crap we don't
want you to tell our daughters that
they're secretly boys or vice versa get
this stuff out of the schools
and what makes the story so interesting
to me
is that this is clearly going to be an
important political Alliance moving
forward and it's a major shift in the
early 2000s after 9 11.
you you did not exactly see the
Christians and the Muslims teaming up in
American politics there was a great
threat from radical Islam the wars that
we were fighting during that period were
against radical Muslims in the Middle
East there were Terror attacks by
radical Muslims in the United States and
so you didn't see that kind of Alliance
but now in the year of Our Lord 2022 the
the major threat to the United States
does not seem to be coming from Al Qaeda
which barely exists anymore Isis or the
radical Muslims that doesn't seem to be
the big threat if I asked you right now
what are you most worried about in terms
of threats against you and your family
and specifically your kids
are you more worried about
some crazy Muslim terrorist somewhere in
the world or are you more worried about
the drag queen who's showing up to your
kids kindergarten classroom it's
obviously going to be the latter and
because that's the threat because the
most immediate threat right now to to
our society is from the radical left
right here at home I think you're going
to see more and more of this kind of an
alliance
religious and conservatives Christians
and Muslims and Jews and just normal
people who are even perhaps even
somewhat vague or agnostic in their
religion but they they prefer a kind of
traditional moral order we are all going
to team up together because we have a
common foe right now that threatens the
very fabric of our society and all of
the the beliefs and traditions and and
virtues that we all hold so dear get
ready for for much more of a CR many
more Christian Muslim rallies against
the creeps who are trying to trans your
kids
they're trying to do it it's an
existential threat when you think about
existential threats to you you obviously
have to get a will that's why you got to
go check out epic will right now go to
epicwill.com use promo code Knowles for
those who have been following the story
Vanderbilt Hospital has agreed to pause
all gender transition surgeries on
minors this is a huge Wing a left-wing
institution has caved to pressure from
us from the right and that deserves some
recognition but the fight is far from
over there is still so much that we can
do to protect kids from this evil
leftist indoctrination one thing you can
do today is write a will many new
parents don't realize how important it
is to have a will in place but the sad
truth is that if you were to die
tomorrow without a will the fate of your
children would be left up to the libs
who pretty much run everything and I
don't know about you but I don't want
the libs deciding anything for my family
luckily our partners over at Epic will
make early estate planning super easy
and super affordable they bundle your
last will Living Well Healthcare power
of attorney HIPAA release and durable
Financial power of attorney plus you can
save 10 when you use code Knolls it only
costs 119 bucks for a single person to
create a will when you use promo code
nulls you will save 10 go to
epicwill.com use promo code Knowles to
save 10 on Epic Wheels complete will
package that is epicwill.com promo code
Knowles
speaking of
problems in the schools specifically the
weird creepy sex curricula in the
schools
the Charlotte Mecklenburg Schools in
North Carolina are apparently promoting
a gay sex guide to seventh graders here
is a mother showing up to a school board
meeting just reading and I have
instructed by the way our editor is to
bleep this very very liberally because
it's actually scandalous and obscene and
I don't want to expose my listeners to
it but this is the sort of thing that
seventh graders are being exposed to in
their schools in Carolina
this book is gay by Juno Dawson was
found in a seventh grade classroom at
collinswood Middle School it was also on
the ELA recommended reading list for
seventh graders at JM Robinson I'm going
to read from chapter 9 the ins and outs
of gay sex starting at page 201 part one
boy on boy sex perhaps the most
important skill you will Master is a gay
or by man is a Timeless classic the hand
good news is you can practice it on
yourself the bad news is each guy has
become very used to his own way of
getting himself learning how to find a
partner's personal style can take ages
but it can be very rewarding when you do
a good is all about the wrist action rub
the head of his back and forth with your
hand try different speeds and pressures
until he responds positively a bad
hideous grasping and shaking it like a
ketchup bottle it's no wonder that 92
percent of CMS graduating seniors aren't
college or career ready when you're
instructing them on how to get bloated
and instead of teaching them how to add
and subtract superintendent you stated
this book was quote brought into the
classroom by a teacher with no intent to
allow students access and Any teacher
that puts material like this on his or
her belt shelf either a bad teacher or a
pedophile who Grooms children
two minutes are up
here Here Lady here by the way I I cut
out some of the most obscene Parts okay
that wasn't and I I don't mean to laugh
at it I mean she's she has a very good
point she says you know maybe if these
kids spent more time learning addition
and subtraction and less time learning
about gay sex maybe their test scores
wouldn't be so bad but the one that
really got me is the ketchup bottle line
and I think this is I don't mean to
laugh but it's so it's so absurd you
wouldn't you wouldn't believe this
if you hadn't heard it I wouldn't
believe this had I not heard that and I
and I'm relatively young and it's I I
was in school relatively recently and so
I know how crazy things have gotten but
constantly when I'm talking to friends
and relatives and just people when I go
give speeches who are in their 50s 60s
70s 80s sometimes they don't believe
that this stuff is actually happening
but you just you just heard it this is
in schools that book which reads like a
cartoon caricature of gay porn is in
seventh grade classrooms it's on it's on
recommended reading lists okay
that is obviously insane and then I love
the defenses that obviously dishonest
defense is that well no the teacher just
brought it in for what his or her own
reading pleasure that's creepier that's
even creepier than bringing it in as a
learning material because then you've
just got a teacher reading gay porn in a
seventh grade classroom surrounded by 12
year olds just what to titillate himself
that's that's even creepier but
obviously it was this part of a teaching
material that's why I was on a
recommended reading list
and and then so obviously these teachers
should be fired the book should be
banned from the schools this is just
complete the school board should resign
if they tolerate this obviously that
goes without saying put that aside for a
second
to the woman's point at the end this is
such an important reminder about the
nature of sin and vice
sin corrupts your soul yes it leads you
down the road to Perdition yes it has
these distorting perverting effects on
your metaphysical self
another big
problem with sin
is that it's such a waste of time
all sin is just such a waste of time
when you could be doing good things and
edifying things and sanctifying things
you instead do things they're bad and
corrosive and just a waste of time think
about the precious time that you you're
12 years old your brain is so malleable
you you could be learning foreign
languages you could be learning
trigonometry you could be learning
history and dates and facts and things
that are going to help you to be
learning to write and and important
things in your life
and then that precious time is being
wasted
learning about how to how to
how to handle yourself and your friends
like a ketchup bottle
what what a
dark sad
in a way kind of funny
waste of time don't do it you will die
we were just talking about epic will you
will die someday don't when you when you
get to the accounting at St Peter's gate
okay and you have to account for your
whole life yeah there's the good stuff
and the bad stuff but then just think
about the waste of time like yeah I
decided in those precious moments of of
beautiful life that I was given I
decided to read read about the ketchup
bottle don't do that do not do that
speaking of sexual confusion
a lot of big divorce stories recently
and I I'm obsessed with the divorce
stories because I think one I don't
think they're A Private Matter I think
they're a public matter because marriage
is a public institution it's the
fundamental political institution and so
much of the rot of our society is
because the fundamental political unit
has collapsed and it hasn't collapsed if
it's just own organic uh progression
it's collapsed because political actors
have intentionally set about to destroy
the institution of marriage for 50 years
now but that creates obviously major
political problems it has to that is
inevitable and so in the potential
divorce case of Tom Brady and his wife
Gisele Bundchen bungee or bunchen I
actually don't know how to pronounce her
name
uh Giselle
was recently spotted visiting a holistic
healer on several occasions and burning
sage
as the rumors of her impending divorce
persist so I looked up the holistic
healer and Sage burner that Tom Brady's
wife is apparently visiting and this is
what it says on this lady's website I
offer a natural and holistic approach to
medicine I'm an ayurvedic traditional
medicine doctor based in the Boca Raton
area not Varanasi India not some Guru
Baba in India in Boca Raton right
outside of Palm Beach okay and I believe
in the power of healing through natural
and healthy alternatives man or
compliments to Western medicine you know
I'm an educator and a Healer with the
mission to teach each patient about the
natural healing powers they hold within
so I I'm not being hyperbolic at all
when I say this
she's a witch she's just this is what
witchcraft is
if you ever were reading a book and you
said what is witchcraft really it's that
that is what witchcraft is and it's so
talk about a waste of time and also
something that will corrupt your soul
This Woman This wealthy famous woman you
know on the surface seems like she's got
everything in the world
she is spending her time
visiting a witch because she thinks
that's going to help her
do you know what will make this woman
feel better Gisele bungen Brady
you know what will make her feel better
than going and visiting a witch and
burning sage
fixing her marriage
it's amazing to me because people will
accuse
modern religious people
who take religion seriously and they go
to church on Sunday and they believe in
a in God you know the Father Almighty
maker of heaven and Earth and Jesus
Christ is only son our Lord and the Holy
Spirit and all the rest of it they will
accuse us of being silly superstitious
oh you you crazy old guy Stuck in the
Middle Ages or something you probably
don't understand science you're just not
a modern sophisticated person
yeah at least I don't go to witches
because all the people I know who mock
traditional religion
they all do weird stuff like this yeah
maybe they don't all go to the ayurvedic
traditional witch in Boca Raton but they
all do weird stuff they do yoga which is
obviously spiritual yoga is not just
stretching yoga involves spiritual
chance and it derives from from Hinduism
it derives from an actual
Hindu religious practice
or they'll they'll go to they'll they'll
do Reiki that's another one of these
weird Pagan occult rituals or they'll
have crystals or you know they'll just
kind of vibe and have energy with the
universe man or they'll say you know man
I'm spiritual but not religious or you
know I'm putting out good energy for you
man and and so the the consequence of it
is
the people who reject traditional
religion Christianity specifically as
being superstitious or outdated
they are the most superstitious people
in the world and ironically they usually
fall back to much older religious
practices they fall back to Pagan
religious practices they go to actual
witch doctors
but in my experience
and in the experience of our
civilization and culture at its height
it is when we go to our traditional
religion we go back to the practices of
Christianity when we go back to the
Bible that we find we lose superstitions
and we get back to really basic stuff if
this lady went to a priest right now the
priest would say Giselle reconcile with
your husband go work it out reconcile
with your husband have a talk with him
sit down do it for the sake of the
family
if she goes to the witch doctor she's
going to say okay well you got to pull
out the tea leaves man and read it on
your palms and the tarot card because
the Mercury's in retrograde and we're
going to burn some sage and that's how
you're going to feel better which one of
those sounds more reasonable to you
the the really modern sophisticated lady
who probably goes to brunch on Sundays
and goes to the witch doctor or
that little old priest with his little
old wisdom who says go fix your marriage
few weeks ago on this show I read you an
email where we were copied uh and this
was from a Harry's Razors customer who
was canceling his subscription and
switching to Jeremy's razors uh he was
so irritated by Harry's virtue signaling
nonsense that he was willing to pay the
extra money to have his Jeremy's kit
shipped to the UK where he lives since
then we have been copied on a flood of
breakup emails from our listeners all
telling Harry's and Gillette what they
can do with their woke razors here's one
quote
hello I've been using Harry's for many
years
I've enjoyed your product however when
you choose to inject yourself into
Political matters and say that 50 of the
country are bigots you make it a very
easy decision for me to cancel why
should half the country have to tolerate
open discrimination simply for having a
different opinion the answer is that we
shouldn't and thanks to the Daily wire
we no longer have to I'll be giving my
money to someone who will use it for
something I support not a company that
openly despises me P.S I am a bald man
and shave my head three times per week
so you genuinely are missing out on a
good deal of money for me this man's
follicle Fallout
is Harry's Financial loss but they have
no one to blame but themselves actions
have consequences and we will gladly
take the lead in holding woke companies
such as Gillette Harry's Disney and all
the rest of them to account
someone's got to do it right right now
when you go to jeremy'sraisers.com you
can get 40 off your Founders kit so head
on over to jeremy'sraisers.com start
shaving woke free and don't forget to
copy us on your breakup email reviews at
jeremy'sraisers.com
speaking of
speaking of the corruption of Medicine
whether we're talking about the witch
doctors in Boca Raton or whether we're
talking about Washington DC
representative Angie Craig she is a
Democrat congressman from Minnesota she
just fell into one of the most beautiful
Freudian slips I have ever seen this was
in a debate with her opponent take a
listen
I will never stop standing up for big
Pharma
and standing against my constituents
so true probably the truest thing that
lady has said in politics she will never
stop standing up for big Pharma she will
never stop
opposing her constituents
now presumably she meant to say I'll
never stop standing up for my
constituents and standing against big
Pharma but that's not not what she said
and why did she make that claim she made
that claim because she wanted to
Institute a price control for certain
drugs
in the pharmaceutical industry
but at a deeper level on issues that are
much more important than whether the
cost of some particular prescription is
30 bucks or 35 bucks or 40 bucks much
more important than that over the past
two years would be the huge power grab
by the medical establishment to the
insane profit of big Pharma and on that
question
even when it endangered Americans lives
specifically when it endangered the
lives of American children Angie Craig
took the side of big Pharma
here's a tweet from Angie Craig
regarding the vaccines she said quote in
case you missed it coveted vaccines are
now available for children under five
years of age
more information about where to access
vaccines here
and she sent that tweet out
saying hey here's how you get your your
zero to five year olds how you get your
little babies and toddlers the kovid
shot babies and toddlers at basically no
risk whatsoever from covid but you got
to get them that shot anyway
Angie Craig sent that out in June of
this year if she had sent it out last
year I I would still think she was
insane and I would still think it was
endangering kids and I would still think
she was Shilling for big Pharma but I'd
say okay maybe at that point some people
sincerely didn't know that the risks of
these vaccines for young people
generally speaking at least very
frequently out outweigh the potential
benefits
who's June of this year
just a few months ago
we've known this for a long time now
we played on the show yesterday a voting
member of the FDA independent panel that
approves the vaccines saying that young
people generally and young men in
particular should not be getting all of
these booster shots they haven't gone
through a rigorous enough review process
and he was a firm no on that and and the
FDA basically didn't care because the
FDA is captured by big Pharma
and what is this woman doing she's
standing on behalf of big Pharma which
is what the entire left does the entire
left which pretends to to be on the side
of the people man and against the
establishment and down with the man and
speak truth to power and whatever they
are the establishment they are the power
they will always take the side of the
entrenched interest against you
half the Republicans will do that as
well all of the Democrats will do that
half of the Republicans will do that and
then there is a
a sizable portion of the Republicans and
the conservatives broadly who stand
against that power structure because the
power structure right now that is going
in and jabbing your three-year-old and
killing your babies and transiting your
kids and opening up our borders and
flooding the country with foreign
Nationals and printing money willy-nilly
and destroying our energy into and all
the rest of it the people who are doing
that are a very very small radical
political minority the vast majority of
Americans oppose all of those things
people are very much on our side here
but that small radical liberal minority
has
effectively all of the power in the
United States they've got at least the
vast vast majority of the power and that
is the side that Angie Craig and all of
the Democrats are on
speaking of Democrats harming children
really sad story there's a former
Democrat mayor of Beaverton Oregon who
just pled guilty in federal court on
Tuesday for possessing child pornography
guys 73 years old he waived his
indictment he pled guilty to one count
of possessing Kitty porn according to
the Attorney General's office they say
according to court documents between
November 2014 and December 2015 Doyle
knowingly and unlawfully possess digital
media containing child pornography and
so he's made this uh guilty play now
which makes it illegal for him to own a
firearm or to vote while in prison
actually in Oregon he'll be able to vote
once he's out of prison or to hold
public office
the reason I mention this is uh not even
to embarrass this guy he pled guilty at
least he's at least sort of fessing up
to it it's a very horrible thing and
certainly in our society you know in a
probably in most societies uh certainly
sensible societies
sexual attacks on children are just
considered basically the worst thing you
can do it's just it's the it's the worst
thing you can possibly do that this guy
his life is basically ruined at this
point I think he can find a kind of
personal salvation if he repents and
atones and all the rest of it but as a
public matter his life is ruined who
knows if he'll make it out of prison
murderers can be rehabilitated in our
society but sex offenders and
specifically child sex offenders they
are truly considered the absolute lowest
of the low in our society and so I I'm
not even bringing up the story to kick
the man while he's down while he's
already paying his price and going to
jail and all the rest of it
it's just a warning to everybody else
is that worth it
is that worth it
this guy a 73 year old guy he had a
public career he clearly was a pillar of
his community
because he had this sick addiction that
he indulged presumably in his own room
on his little computer with the blinds
turned down what he what he thought was
totally private life his life is ruined
for what to be a little titillated by
this perverse thing
now the the child pornography is the
most extreme example of this
but this is true as I mentioned earlier
about sinbro this is true of all sin
this is true across every single sin all
the way down to eating a little too much
at dinner you know although I tend to
gluttony or anything else the question
is is it ever worth it is that momentary
disordered pleasure worth
destroying your reputation destroying
your family life
this guy is not going to be able to see
his grandkids at least unsupervised and
ultimately destroying your soul and
salvation is it worth it
of course not and it gets to this real
danger I I'm specifically sensitive to
this because of how many of our
listeners write in saying they've got
porn problems I'm I'm just showing this
to you to show you the The Logical
conclusion of that kind of a thing we
are living in an age where
paradoxically
everything is private
and nothing is private everything is
virtual and digital and it's all can be
done from the privacy of your own home
in a tiny little room where you think
you're totally alone but because it's
the internet because it's data because
it's going through Telecom systems
nothing is private at all everything is
being recorded
so I in a way I feel bad for this guy I
feel bad I feel worse for his victims
the Victor the child sex abuse victims
who you know were photographed or
videotaped or whatever but I feel bad
for this guy too and the way that I feel
bad for everybody who commits crimes and
sins it's just
it's so corrosive it's it's and it's
such a waste of time it's so obviously
not worth it let this guy
let this guy be a lesson to you
you know now we are getting to my
absolute favorite time of the week when
I get to hear from you in the mailbag
the mailbag is sponsored by Pure Talk go
to puretalk.com
select a plan enter promo code Knowles
Canada w-l-e-s to get 50 off your first
month
all right let's get to the voicemail
back first question up
hi Michael my name is naylin I'm from
Colorado I just had a quick question
about something they're trying to pass
in my town right now called ranked
Choice voting I was a little skeptical
about it because I saw what happened in
Alaska as well as when I look at the
supporter page almost all if not all the
supporters were Democrats and obviously
when you see that you got to be a little
skeptical you got some alarms going off
so I'd love to hear your opinion on
ranked Choice voting whether or not you
know if it really is Democratic or not
and and why you think it's bad or why
you think it's good thank you so much
ranked Choice voting is awful all
Republicans and conservatives should
oppose it you just saw what happened in
the special election in Alaska Alaska is
going to be sending a Democrat
Congressman to Washington D.C even
though the Democrat Congressman got
fewer votes than the Republican options
broadly the I think it was 40 percent or
less of the vote because the Democrat
was
number two you know because the Democrat
was the lowest common denominator the
Democrat is going to make it to
Washington D.C and that's what ranked
Choice voting does
one it makes the whole thing much more
complicated much more involved in terms
of time and so that gives Democrats a
greater opportunity for fraud when you
drag out voting Democrats usually are
better than Republicans at turning that
to their advantage but but it also just
by its very nature
privileges the lowest common denominator
okay well this is the candidate that I'm
voting for but I would settle for this
person
well that other candidate is the one
that I'm voting for but I would also
settle for that same person that the
other guy would settle for okay I guess
we'll just go for the guy that we
settled for
so it's it's the lowest common
denominator and it it uh results in a an
even lower form of democracy than we
find ourselves in now so very very bad
idea you should oppose ranked Choice
voting it's a total lib op
next question
hi Michael my name is Edward and first
off I wanted to say thank you for going
over in your show on Wednesday how to
actually send in a voicemail by question
um with the very detailed instructions
appreciate it uh my comment is actually
about that same episode where you were
responding to the I guess Tick Tock guy
who said that homosexuality is not
disordered because of what the American
Psychiatric association says since 1973
and I just think that that's obviously
not what he actually believes because of
that
uh Association tomorrow change the
definition to say homosexuality is
disordered I don't think he would say
yes I agree it's actually disordered I
was wrong he'll say no it was something
else uh some other reason so what are
your thoughts on pressing the left to
defend what they actually think instead
of coming up with excuses
um like what the American Psychiatric
association says thanks
they'll never defend what they actually
think because what they actually think
is delusional and and this is true going
back not just 10 or 20 years this is
true going back to the Garden of Eden
this is true going back to as George
Bernard Shaw described the Socialist
playwright then quoted by John F Kennedy
and by Bobby Kennedy and by so many
Democrats since then so some people see
things that are and say why I dream
things that never were and say why not
the former is the conservative Godly
view of things you look at the world you
accept the world as it is you are
curious about the world you want to
understand the world better and you you
want to understand the creation to be a
good Steward of it and to know better
the mind of the Creator and the the
latter view is the liberal view of the
world I see things that never were and
say why not and you try to create a
world of your own that is divorced from
the realities of the world given to you
by your gracious God and maker so the
libs can't
can't pull themselves away from that
because their their view is Fantastical
and delusional and so the only thing
holding it up is the the
sincere uh defenses of people you know
well the American Psychiatric
association says well the American
Medical Association says the boys are
really girls well the this teacher says
boys are really girls well Joe Biden
says boys are really girls yeah they all
say that but it's just made up
show me where that is in nature show me
where that is in philosophy show me
where that is in reality and they can't
do that so no they'll they'll never get
Beyond these kinds of arguments from the
authority of their own delusional their
own fellow delusional men that that's
where it comes from in the first place
next question
hi Mike it's Arielle
I have a question for you
and I do feel like it's pretty weighty
one
you talk about a lot of really important
topics on your show
you delve really pretty deeply into a
lot of them and you have some really
great analysis but I do feel like the
question that I am going to ask you is a
tough one and it's probably going to
stretch you a little bit
so here goes
is it pumpkin spice latte
or is it pumpkin spiced latte
I look forward to hearing
your answer after what I'm sure will be
quite a bit of thought thanks Mike
it's a really good question it is the
hardest I'm not joking this is the
hardest question I've probably dealt
with all day I cautiously lean toward
pumpkin spice latte
because I think that
I don't think that
pumpkin spice is a verb in this context
you're gonna pumpkin spice that guy oh
yeah bro I pumpkin spiced him real hard
you know pumpkin spice that drink for me
okay it's pumpkin spiced
I think it is
a latte defined
by a noun and you just kind of mash up
pumpkin spice latte like a caramel cold
brew you wouldn't say carameld cold brew
you just say it's the noun caramel and
and cold brew put together and so the
the that that is the caramel does Define
the drink but it's not acting as a verb
I was thinking about this with iced tea
because I so usually write out iced tea
but then I thought maybe it actually is
iced tea
because I don't ice the tea like I'm
going to shoot the tea you know like hey
man I totally iced that tea yeah bam bam
bam bam yeah that tea got totally iced
no just ice it's ice and tea iced tea
so I cautiously lean toward pumpkin
spice latte but I could be convinced
otherwise next question
Mr Knowles how's my favorite host of The
Daily wire had a question for you uh
regarding a dilemma I have so I have a
friend of mine who is a very big fan of
my band purging sin
and
he is transgender
he basically dresses up in women's
clothing he's on hormones
but he still has his male appendages now
I value his friendship and the fact that
he has been
a huge fan of our band for the longest
time and would really hate to break off
this professional relationship as a
result of difference of views
and to top it all off he's very
conservative pro-trump
so my question to you is in this
situation how would I retain my
friendship with this guy
but at the same time too
Express that I do not believe in what he
believes in shout out to Davies and the
fourth Thursday cigar club
is that slap my base
is that that might be slap my base
that's a great daily wire remember great
Michael Knowles show member uh
what would I do if I were in your shoes
I would
remain friends with the guy if you can
and just
view that friendship and view him as you
would any other friend who has a mental
illness because it obviously is a mental
illness if you're a man and you think
that you're a woman and you behave that
way I have plenty of friends and family
members with mental illnesses especially
you know I grew up in New York I think
there's a higher a higher proportion of
mental illnesses in New York something
about the city or something but I would
yeah I would treat it like you have a
friend or a family member who's bipolar
who has uh I don't know some kind of
mood disorder or or someone who has
schizophrenia or even you know has
transgenderism
I
I'm trying to think if I still have
friends who are transgender I have had
friends who are transgender and some of
whom don't speak to me anymore because
they're very upset that I won't uh
affirm their delusions but I I've never
broken up a friendship because someone
has some weird sexual hang up quite the
opposite I'm I'm always happy to spend
time I've gotten along with Blair white
you know who's in the media and had
Blair on the show and
he and I got along just fine I I always
get get in trouble with a very small
number of people on the right who when
they're trying to attack me they'll
they'll point to a photo I once took a
photo with a transvestite at a big
political convention and
I I
I I think they're very upset that I was
nice to a transvestite guy I thought I
have no reason not to be nice to a
transvestite guy I would never lie to
him and tell him that he's really a
woman I would never uh say that the
society
should tolerate or encourage
transvestitism or transgenderism but I
see no reason to be nice to somebody or
to have a friendship with someone who's
confused I think what's required is a
little bit of humility you know as is
often the case what's required is just a
little bit of humility and recognizing
this is a fallen world and and uh so you
speak the truth with love and the truth
as far as you can see it and you
recognize that you've got flaws too and
your friends tolerate you for all of
your many flaws and problems and
struggles and and so you should do the
same to other people it does you should
not squish at all you should not call
him by his woman name or whatever you
know or call him she or something but
yeah yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't not be
friends with a guy because he's mentally
ill that seems like the time you should
most be friends with a guy okay let's
get to the the physical written mailbag
from Eric
uh Eric dear Michael for the last two
years I've been working maintenance at a
job that I absolutely love
my girlfriend and I have been together
over a year now I love her greatly and
have every intention of marrying her a
year before we started dating however I
developed a crush on a girl at work
since I've been dating my girlfriend I
have no more interest in this work Crush
but still find her very attractive and
can't help asking myself what could have
developed between us do you have any
advice on how to avoid that nagging
question respectfully Eric
uh yeah that question is a constant
for men throughout all of time in all
places that's just part of our nature
so it's funny because you say you have
no more interest in this girl but you
still find her attractive and you wonder
what could have been so obviously you do
still have an interest in this girl but
you have this girlfriend so you have two
options you can break up with your
girlfriend and pursue this other girl
you've been with your girlfriend a year
you say you want to marry her but are
you engaged yet if you're engaged then I
would say
I said certainly if you're married I
would say okay then forget about that
but you know if you're just dating and
you're not you haven't expressed that
you actually are going to marry her yet
then you have a choice to make either
can either break up with your girlfriend
and date this girl at work or
date your girlfriend and then maybe get
engaged and get married and put the
thought of the girl at work out of your
head
it might be you might be thinking about
this girl at work because she really is
beautiful and there's really something
about her that you really like or what I
think is probably even more likely is
you are projecting onto the girl at work
your kind of fantasies and desires and
dreams about you know some ideal woman
who doesn't really exist in reality it
could be either I don't know the girl at
work I don't know you it you know so it
really could be either but either way
you have an obligation to put that woman
out of your mind
if you are going to seriously date this
other girl and get engaged and get
married
and it's not just to say well what's
that you know what's the do I think
about baseball yeah sure think about
baseball think about Grandma do but you
have an actual Duty because the thing is
the more you think about the girl at
work and you fantasize about her and you
think what could have been and you
formulate this whole fantasy in your
head the more attracted to her you are
going to be the harder it's going to get
not to think about you're going to think
about her more and more and more you're
going to flirt with her more and more
and more maybe you you go out on a date
with her or something maybe something
really physical starts to happen
and the more you put her out of your
mind
and you say that's over even if I really
really wanted to date her too bad I've
made my choice and I'm sticking with my
choice
the less you're going to think about
that girl the less you're going to be
tempted the less you're going to be
attracted to her and you're just going
to move right along but you've got to
make that choice it's not just a matter
of being swept away forever on your
emotions I think of kanto5 of The
Inferno by Dante is the the adulterous
lovers who are their punishment is to be
blown Forever on the Winds of of their
own passions because they can't control
it and how did they start Apollo and
Francesca how did they start this was an
adulterous Affair between a woman and
her brother-in-law it's because they
were reading to each other they were
reading Lancelot Gallia you know and the
galiato and their their
they're they're reading about this love
and so they're they're really taken by
the fantasy of this other love of you
know the Knights of the Round Table and
that fantasy drives them together and
then finally one day they read no more
they put the book away they get down to
business and then her husband comes in
and kills both of them and and Francesca
says to Dante lamenting she says
the love the love
which to the the gentle heart Gentile uh
you know sort of seizes you seizes you
up by this passion a lot love which does
not uh permit any lover not to love love
led us to one death
and and so it was it was not
fixed from the very beginning that she
had to be taken away on this love she
indulged her fantasies and so did Paula
they indulged their fantasies and then
that led to the really bad conclusion so
what you have to do is stop indulging
those fantasies make your choice you're
a man you've got intellect and free will
love your girlfriend
or dump her and love this other girl but
make a choice the rest of the show is
continuing now there are uh fake
headlines that we need to
we need to work through today okay this
is Friday on Friday it's fake headline
day Davies picks out five headlines for
a real one is fake I had had a perfect
score
now I don't I got it wrong last week I
need you to help me in the comments
section to pick out which one is the
fake headline you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us see you over
on the member block
[Music]
[Music]